[Applause]
there's no place like home you're going
to need a bigger boat frankly my dear I
don't give a damn we'll always have
Paris is it safe leave the gun take the
canoli this is
fun what's that from no I'm just saying
it's fun seeing lines from some of the
best scripts ever written based on
material previously produced or
published with my brains and your looks
we could go places never a truer word
spoken
Josh thank you God that was my Nicholson
that was one of the worst Nicholson's
ever done in the history I'm sorry man
I'll buy a drink afterwards okay no I
apologize anyway uh the nominees for
best screenplay based on material
previously produced or published are